[Musique]
tout est pas trompée avec ou sans moi
à malines
[Musique]
mais tu peux pas attendre
bien manger bien
bon courage à toi tout tient pour la
fois
réfléchissez allez courage avait subi
une courage
fini plus cauet
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
yahia il m'a monté cela montre juste
prix ganay
[Applaudissements]
allez on y va
tb finalement les bien banal est sympa
avec moi et me demandant mon que nous ça
fait aujourd'hui
4 comment les jolies
et comme ils pensent que m'avait pas
envie de venir ma vivent une aventure
incroyable
et comme imagine tout ça ni en temps
comme une mélodie des sentiers
[Musique]
dans la ravine dans quel soleil
leclerc est grave parce qu'avant
et la place
je lisais
la cohésion de france en soleil
[Musique]